So, you know when it comes to motion
graphics, my tool of choice is Apple's
Motion, especially for making motion
graphics for Final Cut Pro, but really
for any NLE.
But, what if you could create motion
graphics
just by talking to your computer and
telling it what you want it to make?
That's what we're going to do today.
All right, what I'm going to do first
here is lay out the components of what
makes it possible to do this
prompt-based motion graphics creation.
And then, I'm going to do a little demo.
Uh I'll show you some examples of some
other work I've done with it, and then
I'm going to show you how you can set it
up yourself. So, what we're looking at
right now is what's called Remotion
Studio. We can see we're in Chrome. You
can see I'm in a local host. I'm just
running a local server, and this is the
Remotion interface. Remotion is the
piece of software that allows you to
create these motion graphics that we're
going to tie into. So, what is Remotion?
Well,
let's play a little a little bit of
this. What is Remotion?
And I'm playing this directly in
Remotion.
Remotion is an open-source framework
that lets you create videos
programmatically using React and
JavaScript. Now, you don't need to worry
about what is React and what is
JavaScript. Uh the basic idea is we're
in this player, I've created these
motion graphics with Remotion by
prompting. You can use code. So,
Remotion, if if you're a coder, if
you're a programmer, you can program
Remotion to create motion graphics
programmatically, but that's not what
we're trying to do here. So, um
instead of writing code to program a
motion, you can drive Remotion with
natural language prompts. Well, how do
you do that?
I'm using Claude code. You can use
multiple different platforms to do this,
but there's a skill that works with
Claude code that makes this really
useful, and I find Claude code to be a a
great AI system for many things beyond
this. So, those are the components, and
this is kind of how it all comes
together here. So, this is the video
workflow that I'm using. We start with
you or me, the creative director, and
then we move down to the brain of the
system.
>> [laughter]
>> You're not the brain anymore, sorry.
Claude code is the brain
that is driving things, and then it
feeds into Remotion. So, it's
using your text prompt, your natural
language prompt, to turn it into code to
drive Remotion, which is the engine that
creates this, and then it feeds back.
And
I created this animation also all with
text prompts
writing Claude code feeding Remotion. I
just told it what to do, and I fed it a
couple images that you see here that I
made happen to make with ChatGPT, but
however you want to make those.
All right. So, let's just try it out
first. I'm not going to explain
everything, but I'm going to go to
Claude code,
and this is in the Claude desktop app on
macOS, and I will get how to set this
stuff up, but right now I just wanted to
show you kind of what it does. And I'm
in a I'm in the code section. We'll get
to these tabs in a minute. And I'm just
going to speak in here. You can see the
the
folder is called my first video, and
we'll get to that as well, but that's
where it's looking. And you can type
into here, but I'm I'm using You can use
Mac Whisper, or I'm using a an app
called Almond that allows me to talk and
turn that into text in here. So, let's
just create a little animation. And the
thing is, you can be very vague, and
then you might need to revise it a lot,
but the more specific you are, the
closer you'll get to what you want to
actually produce. So, let's try this
out. Okay, I want you to create a new
composition of a
opening
title animation. I want the title to say
"What can I do with Remotion?" with a
question mark.
I want it to be uh almost black text,
like dark gray text on a white
background, a large font so that it
almost completely fills the screen
horizontally, and use a nice modern
sans-serif font.
And let's have the text come on say
a word at a time, both scaling up and
fading on from zero opacity.
And let's also, while the text is fading
on, let's have a like a
parallelogram-shaped box
slide in behind the text and also be
offset from it, like maybe it's dropped
down, I don't know, 100 pixels and to
the right maybe 100 pixels.
And um
it's going to be a black box, so where
the text overlaps that, that black text
should be inverted and turned white.
Okay, so I was just uh holding down the
function key to record that, and there's
my description, which I can just do
faster than typing. So we're going to go
ahead and send that off. This is also my
model choice, by the way.
And we'll talk about more about that
later. This is just a little cheaper
than the Opus model.
So um it's sending it off. It says it
gives you a bunch of
uh
feedback about what it's doing, and it's
going to ask for permission the first
time through this. And I I recommend you
you can turn these off so that it does
it automatically, but I'm just going to
command return to accept that.
Uh
and let it keep working. And now it's
reading the rules
in the folder that I pointed to to
understand uh what it needs to do,
looking at the project structure. Now it
says I have everything.
And uh it's looking at the directory.
There's already uh what I can use motion
for component because I I tried this out
before. Uh so, it's rewriting it. I I
should have given in the composition a
specific name, but that's okay. Let's
just let it do what it's going to do and
see what it comes up with.
I'm going to let this run in real time
so you can see
how long it takes.
Um
you'll also notice uh the studio server
has disconnected. I've been having a
little bit of a problem with that, but
it's easy to fix.
So,
the key is I know we're sitting here and
watching this right now, but you can be
doing other things.
Because I could create this thing in
motion
uh
pretty fast, but it's it's [laughter]
done.
So, let's fix the fact that the the
server's dropped out. So, I'm going to
say the studio server
has disconnected.
And let's see if it'll fix that. It
usually just takes a second to restart
it.
All right. So, uh
what can we remove remote motion for?
So, let's see. I'll go back and play it.
What can I do with remote motion?
And it did pretty much exactly what I
asked it to do. It's not beautiful, but
it's cool.
But uh very easy to modify. So, we can
go back now and say
that's great, but now let's have the
parallelogram box be large enough to
completely encompass the text as it
slides in. And then after everything
settles and stays on the screen for
let's say 2 seconds, let's have it all
go off the screen. And this time I want
the parallelogram box
to scale up to fill the entire frame so
everything goes to black while the text
animation scales down a word at a time
and the opacity drops to zero.
And we'll let that kick off.
And let's take a look at it.
And again, you can be very very specific
about fonts and sizes or you can just
kind of take a stab at it and see what
it does. You can see what it's doing
now. It's planning out what it's going
to do.
Um it can be good idea also to do this
in little pieces and you can start by
saying, "Hey, I want this whole
composition to be say 30 seconds long
and
let's just do the first 5 seconds." You
can break it into little steps and that
can help it figure out what's going on.
It's really a matter of just kind of
working with it and going back and forth
and seeing what you get.
You can see it's working out the math
now to figure out exactly how to do
this.
What I was saying before is you can be
doing something else while this is
working. That's kind of the key thing.
Even though uh sometimes it might need
to think for a couple of minutes
um
and you might be like, "Hey, I could
build this in motion just as quickly."
But you're building the whole time and
here you're giving it some direction.
You're you're moving on.
And allowing it to do its thing.
Okay, it says it's done. So, let's take
a look and see if it's any better.
So, it didn't quite understand what I
wanted to do there.
But not a bad job there.
And I could keep fooling with it, but I
think that gives you the general idea.
So, I want to show you some other things
that I did with it here.
>> [snorts]
>> Uh the first thing I did is I just told
Claude, "Hey, I'm interested in
exploring this." And Claude said back to
me, "Okay. Hey, I'll make some things
for you." I didn't give it any direction
at all. So, on its own it said, "Hey,
I'll make you a lower third and a title
card and some kinetic text and a logo
reveal
with no input from me whatsoever.
Although, it does know a little bit
about me, Claude does, because of my
file that explains. So, it made this
with zero input from me at all.
Same with this title card.
MacBreak Studio. Again, I didn't even
tell it
to say MacBreak Studio or motion
graphics or give it colors or anything.
It just made that based on what it knows
about me from some previous interaction.
This one's not great, but it's kind of
amazing it just kind of made it. And
then it did a little logo reveal, which
is not a real logo, but
considering I didn't tell it to do
anything and gave it no direction, I was
kind of amazed by that.
It then tried to do a what it called I
said, "Hey, make something a little more
advanced." And it made this
with a little floating particles in the
background. Again, I really didn't give
any direction.
And then this quote-unquote
pro lower third.
Which is not bad.
Okay. So, here's the thing. It's not
great at everything. It can't do things
in motion like sophisticated particle
effects, really sophisticated 3D text
animation, replicators, paint strokes.
Although, it can do some of that stuff,
but it can't do everything. But, there's
a couple of amazing things to me that
you can't really do in motion. So, for
example, one thing I did is I created a
little spreadsheet of some data.
And uh just as a simple mock-up. So, I
created 6 months of data called red
units and blue units.
And I told it to make an animated bar
graph based on this. I a very short uh
prompt. I said, "Make an animated bar
graph
using this." And this is what it made
for me in a in a matter of a few seconds
or you know, maybe a minute.
All right, so I I think that's pretty
amazing that it could just do that right
away by feeding it a little spreadsheet
and creating an M graph. And that's
something you can't do natively in
Motion. It can't work with the data in
this way.
Another thing I did
was I fed it a different little
spreadsheet
where I created several different names
and titles. So, sometimes you might need
to make lower thirds for a documentary
and you've got 30 [snorts] of them or 50
of them or whatever it is.
And instead of making them manually
you can feed a spreadsheet to remotion,
actually to Claude code, which will then
talk to remotion and do it for you. Now,
there's there's been importers for
Motion over the years that have done
this. I don't think there's anything
currently available, but check this out.
Again, I just fed this into Claude code
this little spreadsheet and I said,
"Hey, use remotion to do this and use
the existing lower third I had made it."
I pointed it to an existing lower third
I had made. And then it exported I said,
"Hey, export these as ProRes 444 with
alpha."
And in a matter of a couple of minutes
I had
each of these
lower thirds
customized with the data from the
spreadsheet
that I could then
take those and drop them right into
Final Cut Pro where I want to use them.
So, I thought those were a couple really
interesting use cases that you can't
necessarily do in Motion. I don't
consider it a replacement by any stretch
of the imagination, but I think that
it's an interesting complement to what
you can do with Motion. And uh you know,
these things keep getting better. So, I
think it's
very interesting. So, let's move on to
set up. Okay, so if you want to play
with remotion yourself, and use Claude
to prompt it, I'm going to show you how
to set things up here.
And I'm going to use Remotion to
go through that little three-step
process on how to set up prompt-based
Remotion.
Step one
is to install node.js.
This is just a runtime environment that
lets you run JavaScript locally. And
it's safe, it's free,
>> [snorts]
>> and I have it recommended because you
will use it for many other things if
you're building anything else with AI.
So, what you're going to do
is go to nodejs.org.
And you can see right here, free
open-source cross-platform JavaScript
runtime environment that lets developers
create servers. That's the key part that
we're doing here.
Web apps, command-line tools. So, you
click get node.js.
And then you click the download the
installer, and then you run the
installer. I've already done it, so I'm
not going to do it here, but fast and
easy to do.
That is step one. Step two
is to create the Remotion project. Now,
in order to do this, we're going to use
You could use Claude code to do this,
but we're going to use terminal because
we haven't installed Claude code yet. If
you haven't used terminal yet, don't
worry, I'll walk you through it. It's
very easy. So, here I am in uh terminal.
Terminal is an application that lives in
your applications folder, but inside the
utilities folder in the applications
folder, or just use spotlight to find
it. And when you launch terminal, it
should look pretty much like this, where
it's pointing at your home folder. So,
my home folder name is Mark Spencer, and
uh my MacBook Pro's name is that right
there, Mark's M1 MacBook Pro. The
terminal is kind of like everything you
can do in the finder, you can do them in
the terminal, and it's always looking at
a specific location where it's working,
and by default, that is your home
folder.
We're going to install a new folder
that's going to contain
our Remotion project. You can choose to
put it in your home folder or you could
put it somewhere else. When I did this
initially, I put it on my desktop, so I
type CD for change directory
to desktop.
And now you can see I'm on the desktop
and it's just easier to find that way.
Right now, I'm not going to do that
because I already have one on my
desktop, so I'm going to CD back to
tilde, which is back to my home
directory. I'm going to install it there
in my home directory.
So, how do we install it? We're going to
use a little command that's very simple.
I'm going to copy paste it so I type it
correctly.
And it is NPX space create-video@latest.
So, what does this mean?
Because we installed node.js in step
one,
we can now use that to access something
called node package manager, which
basically there are a bunch of existing
packages for JavaScript that exist that
you can download and install now that
you have node.js installed.
>> [snorts]
>> And this will look for the one called
create-video that's was created by
Remotion and put it and install it for
you. So, I'm going to hit return.
And it recognizes it and says, "Hey,
there's a bunch of
default templates you can install in
here."
I'm just going to choose the default,
which is blank, a blank empty template.
And hit return.
It asks for the name of the directory
that we're installing it. This isn't
where because we're already in the place
we want to be, in my case, in my home
folder, but it's the name of this folder
created in there. By default, it's
called my video. You can accept that or
change it to something else. I'm just
going to call it my-remotion
-projects.
Good to not have any spaces in these
names.
Then uh it asks if we want to install
Tailwind CSS, which is the style sheets
which will allow us to format things.
So, I just say yes. Agent skills,
absolutely. This is the thing that your
agent, in our case Cloud Code, is going
to use to teach itself how to use
Remotion.
So, it found the skill. The skill is
called Remotion Best Practices.
And it also detected a bunch of agents
that I have. So, I can install for all
agents or specific agents. I'm just
going to go ahead and say install for
all agents.
And I'm also going to install in the
current directory, which is where we're
working.
And then I'll say yes to that, too. And
yes to that, too. I'm just hitting
return for everything, basically.
Now,
it's already copied it.
And it's giving me some resources. Uh we
can look at those later. These are
useful to look through.
But, I don't want to open in VS Code. VS
Code is an IDE, a integrated development
environment for coders, basically. We
don't need to use that. So, I'm going to
say no to that.
And now we're back to our initial
prompt. That's done. So, in fact, if we
now go to the finder,
go to our home folder, we can see I've
got a new my Remotion Projects folder.
And if I look in it, these are all the
components of this application.
All set up in here. You don't really
need to deal with any of these. You
could always read the read me
that explains a little bit about it.
But, we're going to use Cloud Code to do
everything else. This public folder is
super useful. It's empty by default, but
if you have any graphics that you want
included, or USDZ files, or video, you
can put them in the public folder and
then tell Cloud Code to include them in
your composition.
So, just good to know about.
All right.
Now that that's done,
we will go to step three,
which is to install Claude desktop. Now
again, you could use
Gemini, you could use
Open [snorts] AI, different platforms to
do this. I like uh Anthropic's Claude,
and I like to use the desktop
application instead of controlling it
through terminal. You could actually
launch Claude directly in a separate
terminal window and use it there. But I
think it's a little easier, especially
for folks that are new to this, to use
the desktop app. So, what we're going to
do is go to claude.com/download.
And here's where you can download it for
Mac OS. And by the way, this is talking
about co-work. Don't worry about that.
I'm going to explain that in just a
minute. This is what just gets you the
application that you can run on your
desktop. So, you click for Mac OS, uh
and then it would download it, and it's
downloading it here, but I don't really
need it cuz I already have it. So, you
download that DMG and install it, and
what you're going to get when you
install it
looks like this. Let's actually create a
new session. It'll look like this. And
it probably it'll look like this when
you first launch it. It'll be over in a
chat window. And you won't have any
chats. I've got a bunch of chats here.
The desktop app has these three modes:
chat, which you probably recognize from
anything else like ChatGPT, where you
can just chat interactively with it.
Co-work is a super cool mode for
accessing Claude code. It lets you do
all kind of things in terms of
organizing files and things. We're not
doing that right now. And then there's
code. Now, you do need to sign up for a
subscription to use Claude code.
And if all you want to do is you use
your motion, you might not want to do
that. I'm using the $20 a month basic
subscription, but I'm using Claude code
to do a lot of other things, and I
highly recommend that you play with it
and learn other things you can do,
especially starting co-work. So, this is
only something to do if you find there's
broader value to you to using
Cloud Code beyond using Remotion. Unless
like, "Hey, for $20 a month, I can make
all these motion graphics. I don't need
to learn motion [laughter] anymore." You
know, go for it. So, the key thing here
is that we're in the code section.
We have We're in a new session. And I'm
going to change this
folder to be the folder that we just
created, okay? So, Mark Spencer, my
Remotion Projects open.
So, that's important because we're
working inside a specific folder.
Now, we should pretty much be done.
Let's see how it goes. I had set this up
earlier in my folder. I know it works.
I had to install dependencies, but I
think Claude should be able to do it for
us. So, what we're going to just say is,
"Can you create for me a simple Remotion
composition called my first test that
includes an animated title?"
Something like that just to make sure
the thing works. Oh, and by the way, you
can choose what model to use. And Opus
is the the strongest, most powerful
model.
But if you're using it a lot, you might
find that you you run out of your daily
limit. Cuz even though you're paying $20
a month, there's a certain limit to how
many tokens you can use.
Sonnet 4.6 which was just introduced is
super efficient and useful and I find it
works just fine for this and you get
more.
So, it's going to ask to trust the
workspace. I'm going to say yes.
And then it's probably going to think
now. It needs to read that skill. I
don't know if you just saw that. It It
showed If we scroll back up, it's Let me
read the relevant rules. And it's going
through and looking at all these
markdown files.
And it's going to ask for permission to
read those markdown files. These are all
part of the Remotion best practice as
you can see right there, the skill.
So, I'm going to press command return to
accept all those.
And now it's looking at the project
structure, trying to figure out what's
going on. You can see it's creating a
component.
Composition complete.
And it says it's done.
Great. So, it says you can preview it
with this command.
This basically means run this command in
the terminal, but let's see if it'll run
it for me.
Can you start Remotion Studio for me?
Because Claude can also run your
terminal. And now it's asking permission
to do so. I'll say allow once.
And I've got to allow it again.
And allow. It would have been faster
just to type this into terminal
ourselves, but I wanted to see if it
could do it because once it's set up and
knows it can access terminal, it'll be
generally do this faster than you could
yourself and it'll also figure out if
something's not working right, it'll
figure out what to do about it.
And it looks like the project
dependencies haven't been installed yet.
Okay.
So, this is what I mentioned earlier
about installing the dependencies.
And you could do it through a quick
terminal command, just run NP NPM
install, but we're just going to let
Claude code do it for us.
Allow again. Dependencies are additional
programs that it needs in order to run.
So, there, it switched by itself. I
didn't do that. It switched by itself
over to Remotion.
And
let's play my first test.
There we go. All right, we're in
business.
Fantastic. So, now You just I'm command
tabbing, switching between Claude and
Remotion, and now we can create a new
composition, adjust this composition. If
we want to add graphics, we can drop
them in the folder, etc. So, it created
this new localhost to run this, and you
can see we have a brand new set of
projects here. If I go back to my own
that happens to be running in Chrome,
you can see my list of projects. And
just to show you again, when I made this
animation, this is what was very
exciting to me is I literally just went
to chat GPT and said, "Make me these
three icons." I dropped them in that
public folder,
and I described what I wanted in a short
paragraph, just talking to it. And it
pretty much got the whole thing out the
gate. I needed to adjust the scale a
little bit, move things up and down a
little bit. And it's not interactive. In
other words, I can't just drag on things
like you can in Motion to quickly
reposition and rescale things. You need
to talk to to do that. However,
if we look at, say,
this lower third, maybe, you can set up
this schema. If it's empty by default,
you can just say to create it. And here,
I can change the text here to be
um
John Doe or whatever, and change the
other text. So, actually, I do have
basically like an inspector here where I
can change the text and change the color
without needing to go to Claude Code and
say, "Hey, just change this little
thing." So, you do have the ability
basically to publish parameters and then
change them. I wanted to come back and
make sure I told you about these couple
of resources that I mentioned that
showed up in terminal when we installed
the Remotion project. So, if you go to
remotion.dev
uh in docs AI Claude Code, this
particular URL will talk to you
specifically about prompting videos with
Claude Code, and basically explains the
install process that we went through.
However, this install process just stays
within the terminal the whole time, and
uses Claude Code within the terminal.
So, it's a little bit different process,
but I wanted to point that out. And
also, if you go under resources, there's
a ton of great stuff here for learning
how to use Remotion,
uh different things, different projects
you can play with to get going. And uh a
showcase of different projects. We've
really just I hate to say scratch the
surface. I think we did scratch the
surface, but you can do much, much more.
And if you look at the showcase, you'll
get some ideas about some other types of
projects that you can make with
Remotion. So, make sure to check those
out. So, that's my
quick explanation of where I am with
using Remotion as an alternative way to
create motion graphics versus Motion.
And I think it's an interesting
compliment. A little bit of setup, a
little bit quirky, but
man, pretty amazing.
Let me know what you think in the
comments below.